hi my name is at sushi second I'm from
possession of new models for us aging
society I am one of the discussion be
there and one important thing that I
have ran from the session is you know in
order to cope with aging population it
is extremely important for us to promote
the employment of older people if more
older people who have the will and the
beauty are able to continue working it
beyond the current retirement age you
know the many of the problems caused by
aging population could be insolvent or
at least the software to some extent you
know the increase in number of active
workers and acting consumers in their
old age will be a driving force of
economic growth both in demand side and
supply side of the macro economy in the
Asian society and also it will reduce I
you know perhaps the garden of a cost of
aging society I mean a particularly the
cost of social security in the aging
society and this is another important
aspect so anyway we need to establish a
lifelong active society in which the
will and the ability of all the people
can be fully utilized and I think in
order to make it possible some of our
public systems including our public
pension system should be devised not to
you know discourage all the people to
continue working also you know at the
workplace the retirement age should be
raised so again in order to make it
possible we need to devise such
employment practices as seniority base
wages that may make you know the
employment of
the people more costly for the employee
anyway these public systems and you know
I employment practices huh a mom major
have existed so we will be able to and
our device or overcome some you know the
negative effect from these institutions
now I'm from Japan and the Japan is now
the world number 1 asian society work I
mean a proportion of all of our people
age 65 years old and over is now almost
one-quarter cattle population so we
definitely need to have a light
non-active society then last year the
late is japan earthquake that struck on
the match of revenue last year and you
know that earthquake and resulting
tsunami you know made a tremendous
disaster on an unprecedented scale so we
should not to fail to reconstruct the
affected area as soon as possible and we
know that a you know the affected area
is even you know faster asian than the
restaurant you can I mean that the
proportion of all the people affected
area is much higher in comparison with
the case of the japan as a whole so we
have to make ready construction and
project under the pressure of aging
formation in the affected in authority
and in fact many all the people in the
affected area have worked to sustain the
local community and to sustain their own
businesses so i think a great outcome
would be if we can make this
reconstruction project as a model of a
lifelong active society in which the
will and the ability of all that
people will be fully utilized and which
is you know necessary for the aging in
Japan in the future as well as the rest
of world sooner or later thank you very
much